cookie clicker is a game about clicking
a cookie
it's simple at first but gets
increasingly complex the late game meta
has elaborate strategies to maximize
cookie production to unlock all of the
upgrades and achievements and to uncover
the deep law of the grandma apocalypse
the crumb lore dragon and the mysteries
of the cookie universe in the beginning
you click the cookie which gets you one
cookie you click again and you've got
two then three
with 15 cookies you can buy a cursor
that clicks for you making cookies
automatically 10 cursors make one cookie
per second or one CPS so you make more
cookies to buy more cursors to make more
cookies and then for a hundred cookies
you buy your first grandma this kindly
old woman performs unpaid labor to grow
your cookie business your cookies become
popular in the neighborhood then
renowned all over town
production accelerates exponentially you
buy cookie farms to grow cookies mine's
to extract cookies from the earth
factories to produce cookies on an
industrial scale the cookie economy
transforms the world around it chocolate
pollutes the rivers there's an obesity
epidemic but the world is too hooked on
cookies to stop economists say that
cookies permeate the economy and if we
start eating anything else we're all
dead cookie banks start using cookies as
currency at temples thousands pray to
the baker in the sky there is no value
no ideology and no meaning beyond
cookies you produce hundreds of
thousands of cookies a second straining
the fabric of reality itself
you build wizard towers and alchemy labs
to summon cookies magically you fly in
shipments from space of cookies from
alien worlds you open portals to
parallel dimensions taking in millions
of cookies per second alien beings and
cosmic Elder Gods descend to taste your
cookies and entire cities are engulfed
in tram
dimensional disaster but the system
can't stop it can only grow cookies are
all we know a local confused idiot says
you've got to admit all this cookie
stuff is a bit ominous time machines
bring cookies from the past corrupting
history with abominations of dough you
make cookies from antimatter from light
from pure chance you make cookies from
other cookies and cookies from beyond
the fourth wall you make trillions of
cookies a second the foundations of the
cosmos crack under the mass of the
cookie economy everything is transformed
either into cookies or into the means to
create cookies the universe becomes
cookie dough down to the molecular level
an infinite sentient terrifying cookie
Gestalt the only escape from the cosmic
cookie machine is death yet not even
that can save you when you're ready you
ascend you leave the mortal world for a
higher plane of cookie existence where
you can buy special heavenly upgrades
then you are reborn into a new game with
zero cookies to start it all again but
you keep certain upgrades and bonuses so
you can quickly reach and surpass where
you were before so birth death and
rebirth are an endless inescapable cycle
of cookie samsara and the mechanics get
more complex cookie clicker is an idol
game which means you're not meant to sit
there clicking the cookie you meant to
leave it on in the background while it
makes cookies for you and occasionally
come back to spender cookies on upgrades
in the early game this passive play
style is efficient upgrades like the
golden lock and the shimmering veil
optimized for idle cps but in the late
game the best way to progress is with an
active play style because every 5
minutes or so
a golden cookie spawns if you click it
in time you get a random temporary bonus
like a cookie frenzy which increases
your cookie production by 7 times for
one minute the best effect is the
building special which temporarily
multiplies your rate of production based
on how many bill
things you have so if you have hundreds
of buildings that can multiply your CPS
by thousands of times over and if you
can stack multiple multipliers at once
you can increase production by millions
of times over so you want more golden
cookies and to get them you need to use
the grimoire the mini-game unlocked at
the wizard tower one of the grimoire
spells called force the hand of fate
summons are golden cookie so by
manipulating the mana pool by
strategically selling towers and by
spending sugar lumps to replenish manner
you can cast the hand of fate spell
several times in a row reliably
generating three or four golden cookies
at once if you're lucky and these
cookies grant multiple building specials
you can generate cps multipliers of
millions of times regular production
making week's worth of cookies in
minutes to optimize these bonuses even
more you need certain plants from the
cookie garden the garden grows cookie
seeds into cookie plants which can
mutate along a complex cookie
evolutionary tree to unlock new seeds
with new effects like Thumb corn buffs
clicking and cheap cap reduces prices
but the real good [ __ ] is baked berries
when harvested baked berries give you 30
minutes worth of cookie production
instantly so if you harvest while you've
got a huge cps multiplier from gold and
cookies you can make months worth of
cookies instantly you can fill the
garden with baked berries freeze them at
maturity and keeps born in golden
cookies till you get a huge multiplier
then harvest all of the baked berries at
once for massive profit alternatively
you can go for the click frenzy golden
cookie effect which synergizes with the
Gods a mock Pantheon Idol once you've
got crumble or the cookie dragon you can
also do some pretty wild [ __ ] with the
Dragons fortune and dragon fly torus
though for a passive play the breath of
milk or air is usually ideal for the
buff to kittens
of course the seasonal events like
Christmas are also essential so you can
upgrade Santa from an elf fetus to a
bulky elf to elder Santa and then to
final Claus who grants dominion of his
realm and a cheeky 20% CPS bonus so the
late game involves of
Araya t of strategies 2 min max for
optimal cookie production but the
cookies are not without cost as
production increases the grandmas grow
discontent you make me sick grandma says
you could have stopped it grandma says
after the bingo Center upgrade and the
one mind tech tree the grandma
apocalypse begins the indentured labor
force at the bottom of the pyramid for
Abele's a hive mind of mutant grandmas
rise and transform the globe into an
eldritch horror scape of cookie based
monstrosity wrinkled flesh tendrils are
visible from space
writhing masses of dough engulf whole
cities spreading across the globe like
an infectious virus the only way to end
the grandma apocalypse is with an elder
covenant you can sacrifice some economic
gain to save everyone but it can
actually be more efficient to continue
the disaster and send everyone back to
work anyway because the grandma
apocalypse spawns wrinkler z' wrinkler
x' leech 5% of cps but when you pop them
they give back more cookies than they
took so you can increase economic
production by risking the lives of the
elderly disaster is actually an
opportunity to exploit the vulnerable to
make more wealth ultimately
the cookie economy is not designed to
help people
it just makes cookies like a virus or a
tumor its nature is to exploit
everything around it for its own
expansion grandmas banks temples every
part of life is perverted to serve the
purpose of the economy nothing is too
sacred to be sacrificed on its altar and
for what what's the point of a massive
global economy if it fails to protect
the elderly and the vulnerable even
those with the most cookies don't really
benefit from the system past a certain
level of wealth you can never spend that
many cookies and it's not like the game
ever ends you cannot win
cookie clicker you just keep making
cookies until you stop or you die you're
just hoarding cookies for its own sake
it's not really about the cookies it's
about the accumulation getting more you
could be collecting any meaningless
number points subscribers small green
pieces of paper past a certain point
you're just making a number go up and
it's not even a real number because like
look behind the scenes you can cheat you
can literally type in a number and print
two trillion cookies out of thin air
their value is imaginary and yet the
lives and health of our grandmas are
being risked to increase this imaginary
number the problem is that a system
designed to make cookies is not designed
to make well-being or justice so
happiness any system of endless growth
of singular purpose that warps the whole
world around one goal can only grow
until it's self destructs and the only
way we can escape such a game is to stop
playing thanks for watching this video
about cookie clicker you can play the
game at the link below the game is made
by or teal and opti consider supporting
them on patreon make sure to click the
like and click subscribe and click the
bell so that our numbers go up
thanks to patrons Jada Phan Shura de
Moraes Jamie star Lisa Pendleton and
legless Legolas she is
you